Thank you. You know,
if Kamala Harris were at the top of the ticket right now and descending to the
white house, it wouldn't happen there isn't support for it in the United States.
The people don't want it. You know,
the FDR couldn't get it through when he controlled his party,
Democrats controlled the house and the Senate, and he was hugely popular. Well,
the support right now is 20% lower for packing the court than it was back then.
It's not going to happen.
I actually read your tweet about Nancy Pelosi and the mandate on,
on my show this morning.
And I was trying to frame it in a way that that will give people,
obviously a lot of my audience likes Trump. So I was trying to say, okay,
if this doesn't work, if this doesn't end up the way you want it to end up,
like, what, what are the silver linings around this thing?
And I agree with you that her tweet or her comment was so over the top that
maybe it gets the Republicans to dig. And then I'm starting to think, you know,
I'm not a status generally in like a traditional sense,
but I'm starting to think that maybe instead of the small government that I
really want, maybe we never really get to that.
But maybe the best thing we could have is sort of like an endlessly stalemated
government like that, that basically just can't do anything.
And then what'll happen is every four years we'll have the guy do executive
actions and then the next guy will reverse them. And that,
and that'll just be the way we're governed. And I know it kind of sucks.
And for those of us that do this for a living,
it's like not really what you want, but like maybe in a bizarre sense,
that's the last fail safe that we have.
Basis stasis could be, could be okay. Right.
I think that the Democrats would much have preferred status to Trump doing
anything meaningful. And I think that's how the Republicans are feeling now.
I mean, I,
my own sense of it is most Republicans aren't that scared of Joe Biden, the man,
because he has a 50 year history of legislating from the middle,
but Joe Biden is elderly and not totally with it mentally from what we've
seen.
And I think a lot of people are worried that he is just going to be the puppet
and people like AOC and Nancy Pelosi are going to be the puppeteers.
And I realized those two women don't have the same agenda,
but as far as Republicans are concerned, neither is good. Um, you know,
you're not going to have some moderate, um, you know,
Joe mansion pulling the strings on, on Joe Biden.
It's going to be people like that, the squad,
and nobody wants a squad getting in there and telling them what to do,
or just pressuring him so much that he does it. So I think Stacy,
this would be okay, but I think it could be worse than Stacy's.
It could be a bloody civil war sort of if you will political.
So for forgive the reference because, um, if they,
if they do go after Trump, if they, if,
if they decide to go after him legally and put them in jail and I'll do
everything and like, you know, completely go after Trump and his supporters,
you know, the Senate does a lot.
If the Republicans control the Senate and I don't,
I know we're looking at two runoffs in Georgia,
but Georgia Republicans have never lost a runoff in the state of Georgia.
Never not realize we're going to have a huge money dump there to try to change
that this time around. But, and George is changing.
It's becoming bluer obviously, but the odds are on the GOP side.
So let's assume for now, GOP can retains control of the they,
if they retain control of the Senate, the Democrats do all those things.
They're going to make it as ugly and as acrimonious and is unfortunate for the
Dems as possible. A lot of these categories just have to be,
they have to be confirmed by the Senate, right? Like what if, what if, uh, uh,
justice, uh, God forbid dies and you need confirmation by the Senate.
Like there there's a lot the Senate can do to stop a president from getting
anything done.
And then two years we have another election and the Democrats share of the house
majority. I mean, it's going down like this. As we speak,
it's getting smaller and smaller and it could get down.
When all of a sudden Dunn's just a four seat advantage by the Dems.
If that happens, they're almost certainly going to lose control in two years.
So politics never stops.
If you are just a complete prick two and four years later,
it's going to come back at you.
Right? And then when you look at some of the interesting numbers that broke in
different ways that the black men voted more than two times as high
for a Republican, as they did last time and black women,
it went up from 4% to 8%. That's not a huge percentage,
but doubling is pretty good. I saw something this morning that 16%,
I think of Muslims voted for Trump.
Like all things that you just wouldn't expect that, that, uh,
LGBT support for Trump actually more than doubled.
So like there are some interesting signs of future.
How worried are you just about general,
like trust in the whole thing like that,
the same people who said Russia are now saying our election is tamper-proof
right. Like, that's the big one that I'm like seeing the hypocrisy on right now,
you guys ran around saying Russia interfered in our elections four years ago.
Now, now you're telling us because you got what you wanted,
apparently that the system is perfect so that people won't trust the electoral
system. They already don't trust the media system. That, that basically,
you know, all of our, the colleges, just the institutional level,
there is just no trust in anything anymore.
And I can't really fake it for people, you know,
like I wish these things were better, but I don't think they are.
Well, some of that concerns me, but most of it doesn't, um,
I think for example, I think Joe,
Biden's not going to pack the Supreme court and that's good because that would
have been a massive move that would have ruined the Supreme court that would
have been the end of the Supreme court. And that would,
would've been a catastrophic breakdown of systems.
If it ain't, what if it ain't Joe? Cause I'm with you on that?
I think Joe actually, right.
Not the forecourt within the democratic party or writ large there, isn't.
You think by him getting in it's it's fed them enough that they won't have to do
like that.
I even think if, you know,
if Kamala Harris were at the top of the ticket right now and is sending to the
white house,
it wouldn't happen there isn't support for it in the United States are the
people don't want it. You know,
the FDR couldn't get it through when he controlled his party Democrats control
of the house and the Senate. And he was hugely popular. Well,
the support right now is 20% lower for packing the court than it was back then.
It's not going to happen. People don't want it.
These politicians aren't politically suicidal.
So that was a good talking point by Jeffrey Toobin who really should have been
more focused on how to work with zoom than writing provocative articles in the
new Yorker about that's never going to happen. Um, and it's, I don't think Joe,
Biden's going to do that.
I think the reason he wouldn't answer that when he was running is because the
answer was no, it was to protect his left flank. Uh, you know,
him from his left flank not to protect himself from the right,
but I also kind of think that distrust in,
in some agencies can be good and it's,
it's not all destructive. You know,
like I think the media needed to be destroyed and,
and now it will rebuild in some way, shape or form. I mean,
I really think I've said this to you before the, the,
the journalists they've been on a kamikaze mission ever since Trump,
I didn't start with Trump, but like he he's the, it was the,
that was the real mission.
They've been on a kamikaze mission to take him down and it wound up being a
thing where they did kill themselves. And in the end, they,
they, it does appear. They took him with them.
It does appear they brought him down because if you don't think the media played
a role in people's perceptions of Trump these past four years,
as controversial as he is legitimately ban,
that I don't mean to give him a full pass on all the crazy stuff he's done,
but the media did so much of it. So they, they are,
they are a force. I don't want to say for evil, that's too strong,
but they're not to be trusted and they're not what they used to be.
And they're not honest about it.
So they needed to be destroyed and we'll see what comes up.
So maybe that's true in the FBI.
They needed to be unmasked as this political organization.
I had complete trust in James Comey, David, I did, I was like,
Jim, call me, I, you know, the guy wrong.
And I'm grateful for having that, you know, that that mask pulled off. And so
I can't totally dismiss the dismantling of distrust of trust and some of these
organs.
Right? Like that. Well, that's what I'm saying.
I'm I'm down with the distrust stuff. I don't,
I don't think they deserve our trust anymore,
but the problem is that it's sort of only got halfway. In other words,
if Trump loses, well, then they'd been on mass, but they're about to rebuild.
You can already feel it a little bit like, Oh, they didn't fully get us.
So here we go. Again, something like.
No, no, I don't think that's right,
because they never lost trust with the Democrats. They've had it. I mean,
we're just going to a more fractured media world.
Like the country used to have when we were founded for the a hundred years
thereafter where, you know,
the left has its sources and the right has its sources. But one great thing.
Trump did was make very clear that virtually everybody is on that
first side virtually, but he is actually fighting for Democrats.
There is not a Republican in the country left.
I think that thinks CNN is fair and objective news.
We may be some people who really don't pay attention to the news. Might,
might still think that Republicans haven't been fooled know th the mask has been
pulled off. So that's a good thing, you know,
and I don't think they're going to,
I think they're going to be defensive of Joe Biden. I think quietly,
the Washington post democracy dies in darkness is going to just get pulled off
the moon. It's no longer dark, so we don't need,
but I think all of that's great and it gives the audience, you know, it's like,
let me, let me put it to you this way.
If you have a friend who's a real jerk and you didn't, you didn't know it. Um,
I'm trying to think of my one friend's example. So I'll get,
I'll give you this friends of ours, interracial couple, the husband's black,
the wife is white. And after the George Floyd thing,
they were very upset because one of their white friends called them up and said,
how are you doing? I hope you're okay. And then they saw, they found out,
Oh no, you know what?
I can't tell the whole story because it will reveal who it was,
but it was somebody who they thought was a friend and who they had helped out
with there, with respect to their kid, getting into college.
They had done a lot to help him.
And basically the guy got outed as repeatedly saying the N word and really
racist stuff about black people. So they were shocked. They were horrified.
And I said to them, you know what, this is a good thing,
because that was the reality yesterday.
And you just didn't know what it's better today to know. And,
and then act accordingly. It's not, it's hurtful to find out,
but it's not better to be in the dark.
And that's how I feel about the media and these organizations,
which really are politically driven,
but we didn't know it may hurt to learn it or not, but it's better to know.
And then act.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling out our media playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.